hey what's up everybody welcome to the
are you garbage comedy podcast please
take a second to subscribe to the
youtube channel that way you get the
episodes as they come out
thanks a lot welcome to another exciting
edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is r u garbage the show where we sit
down with your favorite comedian and
find out if they grew up classy
or if they're just a complete piece of
[ __ ] i'm your host h foley coming at you
on a beautiful
evening here in uh bluebell pennsylvania
screen doors in time the grill's going
the pool is wet
and dirty my co-host
back in the big apple going out
gonna give it one more shot folks
he's gonna try and try to make good
putting it all on black baby let's go
ladies and gentlemen our old pal the
brains behind the operation mr
kevin james ryan hey what's up everybody
thanks for listening happy to be here if
you haven't already please make sure you
rate review subscribe on itunes get
those up
and full video available on youtube you
can subscribe there as well we really
appreciate it yes sir before we get the
episode started let's get into a few
fan submissions
guys if you haven't already uh the
patreon is up and running and we get so
many um
listeners submitting their own garbage
questions that we can't get to all of
them some of the good ones
we'll you know we'll we'll use but um if
you join the patreon we'll
automatically read one of your questions
so that being said we're going to each
episode we're just going to run through
a couple in the beginning of the episode
to uh to get them out of the way
what are you laughing at i like how you
said some of the good ones you sound
like a little league coach
and kazansky you suck all right they
can't all be mvps you know what i mean
yeah so guys there's three levels to the
patreon the first level is trash you get
a bonus episode of are you garbage every
week with me foley and a guest the next
level is
um garbagio which is a little bit
classier you get that same episode plus
you get an episode of hard feelings
which is just me and foley being me
and foley at our kippy and foleyist
and then there's uh the top level as you
filthy animal where each month we'll
play with everybody from that group
we'll play are you garbage in a live
stream um with all the with all the
listeners
so sign up check it out and the first
goal which we're almost
at is once we hit our first hundred
patrons after that we're going to go
into foley's house and do an mtv
cribs garbage edition and look at that
[ __ ]
that trailer that he grew up in which i
can i can see the picture of your dead
grandmother in the back already
i'm about to start yelling at my mom you
hear that dog barking hey i'm working
over here
get out of here
that's your dad waiting for the hot dog
all right let's [ __ ] get into it here
what up get that grill
all right we're going to bang the trash
cans together
get out of it um so we're just going to
run through five right now
this one is this one is
from sam squire shout out to sam
have you ever used a stove for something
other than intended example home heating
lighting a cigarette knife hits etc
knife hits yeah i think it's where you
like i know that kind of drug
i don't know if it's meth or crack or
crap i believe it's marijuana
yeah you would heat the night off and
then you put like maybe some hashish
or uh something like that on the hot
knife and um
you kind of freebase it so i've heard
that's what you're that's what your
mom's doing up in the kitchen right now
my favorite thing i had for dinner huh
um
i for sure have my mom used to heat the
in the morning she would just turn the
oven on and open the door to the oven
instead of like heating the whole house
she would just heat the kitchen that way
wait the heat wasn't on throughout the
night it was but i guess if it was cold
i don't know she would just open up to
crack the stove
i know you're [ __ ] dressed oh
yeah dude also my dad i don't think
there was a lighter in my house from
1991 to 97. he just [ __ ] lit
his marb his marlboro reds off the
[ __ ] burner oh
man if that ain't a [ __ ] garbage bag
move i don't know what is
lighting your smoke off the stove yeah
cause there's two schools of thought on
that you either get down there with your
face and because you have to take a puff
gotta get some oxygen flow through there
for sure and when you just put it in
there into the oven like when you reach
your hand down
it's just burning like you have to bend
over and like get your face in there
get a hot one he says those brows he got
to get up on that pilot light
um i used to he used to do it all the
time and
also you know what's really garbage we'd
go over his buddy's house
at the time and uh no longer friends
and we'd go we'd go over his house and
he had an electric stove
and my dad would do it on that youtube
he would have to sit there for like 10
minutes so that puppy got warm enough
sitting there puffing on it yeah that's
like a car liner man there's nothing
like when a car later
over either too hot or too cold you're
like
dude you know what i used to go with
with uh
with carla i don't think they make them
anymore but the car letters some they
would get like
you know malfunction you would push it
in and it would shoot out like once it's
hot it would pop
because they used to pop out remember to
let you know they're done well some
would like shoot out under the seat
you'd be [ __ ] swerving all over the
car that's the toddler in the face
i put one on my tongue when i was a kid
for some reason
i went to bed yeah just i i put it on
hot
or i got it hot it up and i just put it
on my tongue it burned my tongue
i don't know why i did it i don't know
what i thought was gonna happen it hurt
so bad
i can't imagine you [ __ ] idiot um
yeah for sure that is uh
it was the stove was definitely used as
not right it's a
intended purpose uh all right the next
one
the next one that we actually doubled up
a little bit from edward fleming
his is has the police have has your
family ever had an incident with the
local police
i don't think mine have
we had to call the cops on some meth
head that was banging on our
screen door one sunday this wasn't that
long ago either
what happened uh you know how it is you
know
some kid neighborhood you owed him 15
bucks you
you beat him on a bag and he was coming
to collect this man's on drugs officer
that i sold him no uh
i know some kid that probably that
didn't move out of his parents house
down there smoking meth he's like a
grown man
you know sad really this this really
could be you talking about you to be
honest with you
grown man in his parents basement smoke
and meth
he came back to my parents front door
with just a screen door too
that's why it's real scary when the
screen's locked
it can come right through that screen
yeah
he like started banging on the screen
going like i need help i need help i
need help
my mom was like oh okay
[ __ ] had five over there in two
seconds
yeah i don't think we ever have we
always kept but we always
you know everything get everything an
irish catholic family everything gets
swept under the rug you never call the
police you know
we there was like a rabid squirrel in
our yard we had to do we had to get rid
of that too
called the cop rabbits you called the
cops on a squirrel
what do you call for a rabbit squirrel
you just [ __ ]
locked the door what do you mean what
was he out front with a baseball bat
what's he gonna do
he's gonna get dizzy and run somewhere
else
he's not waiting for you to come out of
your house dude you called the cops on a
squirrel that's what my [ __ ] tax
my my tax dollars are going though you
don't live in this township
so i mean i pay sales tax in some places
i'm sure i'm sure you wet your beak on
that
you can't just let it go if it gets one
of the kids in the neighborhood when
they're going for the ice cream truck or
something
well then that's that's natural
selection daddy if you get bit by a
rabbit squirrel you kind of had that
coming
all right this thing was mean man i
called it this kid they showed this guy
that showed up was real green he was a
rookie
he didn't know what to do he drew his
gun on him at one point when he started
moving towards
us officer harry potter yeah hey kid
take it easy
relax um and then this one's also from
al ponce pontillo um shout out who he
hit us up
him his wife and his kid all listen to
the show shout out to you big al
that is awesome and i think we might
have touched on it before have you ever
had to call the cops on a family member
yes wait what have you ever no
no yeah we did go over that question
that that question was
a question on uh the show are you
garbage
yeah and did you i don't i'm saying did
you not you had did you know yeah i
don't think i'm not trash
call the cops on it we're fighting
that's it we're fighting
you guys guys had a couple of beers okay
yeah we're getting to a fight um
and then this one's from rusty shout out
to rusty have you ever uh
filled your pet's water or dish bowl
with beer
no i've never given the dog beer before
yeah for sure
yeah for sure in the 90s that was the
[ __ ]
move you couldn't do anything cooler
than being a dog drinking beer unless
you were
right unless you were surfing or [ __ ]
spuds mckenzie or whatever his name was
your dog drinking beer spuds mckenzie
what
airbud what the little [ __ ] that played
soccer
air bud was basketball why would his
name be air bud and he played soccer
that doesn't make any sense you don't
catch air in soccer
you talking about the movies about the
golden retriever
yeah i thought he played soccer
[Laughter]
nothing wrong with the dog you know what
i mean i just saw great my sport
dogs can't play soccer you didn't play
basketball no sponsor mckenzie because
he was a cool dog and he was a sponsor
for a beer company
i don't even know who sponsored mckenzie
is hey you're a young kid you don't know
what's going on
a lot of things happened before you got
here trust me okay
we got we got my buddies my buddy got a
a dog
it was like a a bulldog or something we
got that thing
[ __ ] up one time i gotta be honest i
don't get a warm vibe
you're not in you don't you don't strike
me as like an
animal guy even like when you tell
stories about uh
uh putt-putt whatever what was his name
mostly
dog's name rusty and he was a cruel
[ __ ]
what do you talk about talking about a
rabid squirrel we had
we had to put him down i put him down in
the living room i just i just
i can't see the ryan's being like
snuggly and nurturing to to a pet
and then you know the way the story
ended you know i get the feeling that i
was right
no we were growing up we were we were
dog peeps for sure
i had a [ __ ] bunch of dogs they all
went you're dead
they all ended up on the farm if you
know what i mean
has your dad ever taken an animal to the
farm you're trash
yeah you're like the jeffrey epstein you
[ __ ] use them and lose them
i don't like this you pay me as this
like [ __ ] you know hate monger
um no man i just said you're not you you
don't strike me as as
and then compared me to jeffrey epstein
because so many different dogs coming in
and out yeah a lot of people use stuff i
mean you don't have to
you know you don't have to compare me to
the world's worst pedophile i just saw
the documentary i don't know what to
tell you
oh that was a tough one to get through
heavy on the victims
heavy on the victims that film that guy
was a real piece of [ __ ]
yeah nada not a good guy and this one
all right this is the last one
um these questions are great by the way
i love this yeah uh
this is from charles and do my buddy
matt this was
a [ __ ] the only it was it's burned
into my my brain
growing up were there magazines stacked
on the back of your toilet
yeah [ __ ] shitty ones yeah
they were there for like [ __ ] three
years i'm like i gotta read this sports
illustrated again
there's [ __ ] dookie on page 13. kids
kids now don't walking into a fresh
bathroom with a fresh
magazine i don't care if it's in touch
or [ __ ] sports illustrated
as long as it's new what is this brand
new
go in there no it's what it used to be
like
i take my phone in there
watch your no-no videos make sure
they'll
make sure you're not connected to the
bluetooth speaker still you know what i
mean
oh dude i'm so big on that
but i'm not not connected to the wi-fi
the bluetooth oh
yeah the car thing's not activated yeah
my airdrop is off jesus christ
i get off the grid before i go perusing
yeah you gotta have your back up against
the wall to [ __ ] have any fun around
here
everybody's watching you man the heat is
on when you're in the bathroom for 32
minutes
christ
ah too funny oh yes we had a stack of
magazines
um and they they would just get then i
don't mean shitty shitty they would just
get like you know they get wet
they're sticking together they're old
they never threw them out there was
never a fresh
cycle coming in no no they died there
that was the graveyard
for it i don't know i don't know how my
parents came across magazines but it
wasn't a legitimate
um you know stealing them from the
neighbors
something they didn't have like a steady
prescription to be like all of a sudden
one day they would be like prescription
subscription you said prescription
it's all trash your family you have to
get a [ __ ] doctor's you have to get a
doctor's
doctor's note to get a [ __ ] time
magazine i got a prescription to
southern living
did you have highlights were you a
highlights kid let me tell you something
if you had highlights at the house you
were a [ __ ]
that was money i only got them at doctor
i only got them at dr persichetti's
office when i went to get my teeth
cleaned
things already circled yeah everything
was already i knew everything was
no highlight subscription [ __ ] down
the line since i can remember
still get it really yeah
you cry [ __ ] blue collar working
class poor man over there meanwhile you
got
[ __ ] highlights let me ask you a
question that ain't cheap they're
probably
and that thing is they get anybody how
much do you think a highlights magazine
subscription
this is what this is what they get they
do i got them early i was older i got
them early
doesn't matter i spelled it wrong
you guys subscribe to high times
[ __ ] panama red over there mommy um
not what they they get you the first
year hey the first year it's a penny
issue and then once the first year
it rolls over and that ends up being 13
bucks a clip
listen i don't know what i don't know
what explanation
[ __ ] denise was giving me not to get
highlights
no it triples every year and they kill a
dog every time it gets sent to you
i don't know what she told you to shut
you up
but highlights wasn't a rich guy thing
that was a salt of the earth thing that
came every week
i might not have food on the table but i
knew what goofers and gallon was up to
that week i'll tell you that
that's what dude that's [ __ ] that's
bougie as [ __ ] you're getting highlights
to your house
only doctors doctors get it okay
and maybe maybe i would steal one every
now and then from dr spada spadafora's
office
shout out to dr spads
um yeah we were we were against my
my family views things like that
subscriptions as scams
so like they think they're like gypsies
you know what i mean they don't like
putting their name in ink on anything
yeah they probably like
a bunch of fake prescriptions big
subscriptions through the years
no they didn't like that we've never
subscribed to anything ever
we've literally never subscribed to
anything ever not even hbo
now now that they even when they got a
little bit of cash they don't even do
hbo
what your personal hbo dude she just got
netflix and she calls it netflax
jesus
they don't watch a lot of tv huh i guess
she's very busy doing other things i
don't
have a lot of time to sit down she's a
big fox news
viewer buddy let me tell you something
about that fox news holy [ __ ] it's on
[ __ ] 40 at my house
every [ __ ] minute of every day just
blasting
yeah they're uh yeah man we don't we
don't sign up for [ __ ] we don't sign up
for sure you keep your head down and you
steal from that you steal from your
orthodontist that's what you do
also this is another one do you ever go
to a doctor's office this is one of mine
i guess
in the house or like the dentist was in
the house we've talked about this
briefly where
i live where i grew up right now
that is most doctor's offices it's
it's on the house you go around back i
used to see a psychiatrist
that was on the side of the house like
the kids are out there playing
i'm [ __ ] in there crying like you
hear like the wife [ __ ] smell dinner
cooking it's like you're just talking to
a neighbor's dad
yeah that's trash dude my orthodontist
would have those dog running around i
remember thinking i'd be like seven
being like this
buddy you got a [ __ ] dander flying
through the air and [ __ ] this
ain't [ __ ] good dude this ain't this
is
my mouth open over here i'm over here
catching flies and you got the [ __ ]
retriever running through yeah pockets
get
yeah that shit's no good you can't do
that anymore i don't think you gotta i
don't strip them all or something
that's gotta be some kind of hippo or
whatever whatever whatever the hell
they're called
yeah you can't do that anymore um all
right guys that's it thanks so much for
um all the new patrons we'll do five
more next episode yeah
already check it the [ __ ] out we love
you guys we appreciate you guys so much
and let's
uh keep this puppy i'm moving gang we
are so happy to have our incredibly
special guest here with us today
we go way back yeah when moses wore
short pants
the old days the streets of philly i'm
talking about the [ __ ] raven
lounge 16th in samson
they used to call the delivery room
because that was a place
where comedians were born my friend only
mean a couple other guys ever said that
i don't think anybody's ever said that
to be honest with you i thought you were
referring to all the weed i sold out of
that place
gang you know him you love him he's the
co-host of matt and shane's secret
podcast give it the [ __ ] up
for matt mccusker everybody thank you
man come on
but the big question is he garbage
i'm looking at that uh studio he's in
that's uh
that's that's no rogan studio back there
that looks like your grandmother's house
look at that globe dude
hold on look what's directly behind him
there's a window behind matt
but it's got one of those water
retention timbers
yeah he's gonna have a look around
problems huh get a little flooding down
there in the cellar
yeah no that's that's where my goes
right to my sub pump
sump pumps are garbage yeah
that's funny holy [ __ ] buddy how the
hell are you man good man i just had a
kid
like three months ago so holy [ __ ] yeah
congrats man
yeah man i'm uh i've been chilling dude
i've been chilling
down the basement doing my thing laying
low playing it right
i like it staying off the grid
yeah man is that your spot down there do
you get hassle
if you get on the basement too long oh
for sure that's that's my main struggle
in life is how much time i get to spend
down here like when i have to surface
then it's a fight come up for some air
there buddy i get summoned up and then i
argue and i come back down the basement
how long have you been married uh about
a year
about this isn't the same girl that when
when we were in philly right no you
married her too right
yeah this is my no that was my first
wife yeah so this is second marriage
yes garbage
[Laughter]
i don't want to say it but trees the
kid's yours right
yes it was like you met her when she was
pregnant and then yeah
i love her man were you uncle matt for
the first two months of her
job no no no
matt's going to live here now
wow that's like a two-person episode of
full house
um where are you oh sorry where are you
at now yeah i'm in philly i'm like right
near the uh
i'm near the art museum i mean i'm in
like technically francisville but it's
it's like it's called it's near fairmont
but i'm like on the dividing line
between fairmont and francisville
yeah i remember i remember in philly
even knowing where
you lived was a mystery you were you
were an enigma
i remember the only time cotton and i
dropped you off at your house one time
and i think it was when you were living
with your brother yeah
and cotton cotton was born and grew up
on
uh 19th street in south philly and when
we dropped mccusker off
as soon as you got to the car he was
like let's get the [ __ ] out of here
because this neighborhood is [ __ ]
shifty i don't know where it was
it was in west philly it was on 37th and
millen yeah it was one of those streets
that wasn't
straight it was like there was like a
ball in the street
if you catch if you catch like a dog leg
left in in a city that's a that's a bad
streak
yeah i used to live in one of those
blocks where there was like three houses
on the entire block
it was awesome and a couple vacant lots
yeah it's [ __ ] real sketchy
i like where did you grow up i grew up
in delaware county so i was
i grew up mostly in garnett valley but
my
family i was born in havertown and then
went out to garner valley
so i'm not one i was in the hills of
delaware county what does your mom and
dad do i kind of feel like you got
you came from a little cash yeah my so
my dad
yes brother started a trash company oh
yeah they had a trash company and then
they sold it and when i was like
i guess like nine and then they started
doing demolition
so yeah cause i knew you were in
construction i remember you were doing
construction at some point i remember
that
yeah i'm prince of trash
[Laughter]
they had so they had like a my my
grandfather had a small cardboard
recycling business
and then he also would do [ __ ] he was
like a huckster he would like sell he'll
go buy a bunch of groceries and like
sell them to people like your neighbors
so he did that gauging people on eggs
listen to two bucks at the store the 202
here
the eggs are 8.50 and you only get 11.
what the [ __ ]
yeah so they did he did that and he was
kind of like a hustle man he did like a
bunch of weird little things but he had
a cardboard recycling company
and then my dad and his brothers worked
for him when they were younger and they
started into like an actual
full-scale transfer station you know
where harrah's casino is in chester
yeah yeah that used to be mccusker and
sons the transfer station
but they sold they sold the company and
then the company they sold it to sold
the land to harris
you're one step away from [ __ ] cage
that's retirement that's like
generational wealth there you would what
was funny was they uh because
because my dad and his brothers all grew
up like you know like middle class
you know we're like lower middle class
one of like 10 kids in havertown
and uh born to a huckster and
they so when the guy the guy who bought
the company off them was wayne hazanga
who he was the guy who owned blockbuster
he owned the miami dolphins oh [ __ ] yeah
he went to my dad and all his brothers
he's like how much do you guys want for
this and they wrote down what they
thought was like [ __ ] you money because
they didn't want to sell the company
so they thought they were writing him
like he was there he was going to see it
and be offended and the guy was like
not a problem he's like i got that on me
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
yes i forgot a zero i forgot a zero
we need two grand more
[Laughter]
just two grand so they thought they were
hitting him with the number this guy was
like [ __ ] you guys i'm out of here and
he was like that's not a problem i can
arrange that today and they're like
[Laughter]
and this is when you were young yeah i
was little i remember one day
my dad came home in a in a navigator
it's a red navigator and
he was like things are going to be
different and i was like really
yeah he was he was kind of i was like
really little and i was riding around he
was like
i made a lot of money we sold the
company and i was like that's what's up
and he's like yeah man
i was like cool got this sweet red navy
now hop in let's [ __ ] go
kid let's go make with the power wheels
old man huh
i don't want a [ __ ] i want a race car
baby that does show like the blue collar
trashiness in your dad that he made a
bunch of money and went and bought a red
navigator
who does that dude that's like that's
kind of a rap video
yeah his his life has been like keeping
my mom and like
ridiculous that was like he bought my
mom in like a diesel excursion for a
while there
oh dude yeah it's pretty funny
it's pretty bad wild dude yeah it was
like the turning point before that we
were bopping around the convert we had
the conversion van with like the
four inch tv screen so that was that's
that was [ __ ]
that was clean living back in the day
dude i thought we were already bald and
then he hit me with the navy and i was
like
this guy's caked up like where do we
watch godzilla he's like we can't watch
godzilla in this car
that sucks dude my buddy used to have
the conversion man with the tv and we
would go sit in the garage
sit in the driveway and just watch tv
and i thought i was [ __ ]
i thought i was the richest man in the
world in the second house dude that's
amazing
dude turn that back seat into a bed and
[ __ ] chill out for a little bit sure
wait did he have the kind of cash though
when he sold the trash business that he
could have just chilled why did he get
in the demolition business just i don't
that's this is the mystery this is a
go-getter
i'm gonna so i obviously come from an
enigma i have no idea how much money my
parents they don't tell me my mom's been
my mom's been trying to convince me
we're poor ever since because my mom
grew up
pretty you know relatively poor and uh
like her it was like a single
parent her dad was a janitor and he she
would like come in
even after all this [ __ ] happened like
the air conditioning would be on in june
and she'd be like turn this off he can't
afford this my dad would be like
the navigator what the [ __ ] you don't
know that she tries to try that [ __ ] in
her head she grew up like that
she was like oh [ __ ] we're gonna get a
big bill and someone's gonna freak out
so i was grown up with my dad ball and
out of control my mom could
see me on poor so like i don't know what
the [ __ ] going on she didn't mind
driving around that [ __ ] diesel
excursion though
she didn't complain about that you sound
like my dad
yeah i tell you what you got to do is
you go over there one night you say
you're gonna i'm gonna stay over have
dinner
maybe get a little wine in them then
once they go to sleep start rooting
around through their uh
their bills desk yes start looking for a
checkbook real quick
see if you see anything yeah a couple of
chase statements
yeah i think they're i think they're
they're totally fine but yeah
i think that's what i think it was i
worked for an electrician who told me
like your dad could have chilled i don't
know why the [ __ ]
and i was like i don't know he just
likes to do stuff but he also does like
to just get out of the house
yeah yeah that's uh i come from same
thing blue collar my parents
you know in the 90s made a little bit of
cash we moved to the suburbs
and uh then it was all squandered away
eventually but
that's i mean like terribly squandered
it was all
[ __ ] my dad was running a you know an
air-conditioning ponzi scheme i think at
one point and just it all came crumbling
down
but uh that's such a blue-collar thing
when like other
blue-collar workers know what other
blue-collar workers have like
the electrician's like your dad could
have retired he squandered a small
fortune
they taught they gossip dude [ __ ] the
the trades gossip like they all know
who's making what
well yeah if you don't pay a bill it's
like everybody in a five mile radius
knows
you didn't [ __ ] pay me for that thing
i did yeah like yeah
it's pretty crazy man but yeah that was
kind of the uh that was the deal it was
like my mom's like rapport and my dad
was like
i think i'm gonna buy another motorcycle
all right i guess i'll just go get a job
oh this is great
your dad is a [ __ ] ricky bobby
[Laughter]
dear lord baby jesus thank you for the
trash business he also has like i think
my whole family
from the mccusker side are all like
slightly autistic too so like he'll get
into [ __ ] so like he got into
he got into like rollerblading
he's he's also like at this time he was
probably like 250 or 60 pounds because
he got
he got rich and got fat immediately oh
he was fat fatter that's great so he got
rich and like immediately almost touched
300
and he's only he's like six feet so he
immediately got fat as [ __ ]
then he's like i gotta scale this down
he quit drinking because that was his
triglycerides were like i think triple
like a normal human being so we got to
chill with that
so he took off so
he would just get into [ __ ] like he got
into muscle cars did that and then like
just
ditched that and then he got into like
rollerblading he
hit his elbow so he quit rolling muscle
cars to rollerblading what the [ __ ]
about it downwards downward move yeah
i think i think his account was like all
right dude let's go to roadblade
then he got into bicycles and so his
basement is just like there's 35
like 1970s so he'll find schweins in the
trash because he still does trash and
then he'll fix them up
so we have like just literally 30 40
bicycles in our basement
that's a cool little hobby though that's
all right yeah that was his first job
when he was little he used to fix
bicycles when he was like
oh that's pretty good then that's kim
he's like i was like six and i was
fixing i was like dude [ __ ] you you're
probably 14.
yeah now i don't want to sound naive
here but you i mean this sounds like a
like a pretty big
you know trash company doesn't that
those businesses tend to fall
to a certain group of people so
and this is this is what happened though
so when they had
so they did mccusker and sons was
operated in the middle of chester during
the crack epidemic
so like they were already like they had
guns like my uncle would get like tried
to get like he got jumped a couple times
and like so they had
they had a uh so that people would break
in constantly and then like with trash
they're scrap metal so they're they'd
have to they would like pat down
employees at the end of the day it was
insane
but they had a guy so they let they let
a homeless man
this guy called time bomb tom would live
in the trash cart
evt my man he was nuts so he would hang
around so they were like look man
we'll buy you a trail he's homeless so
they bought him a trailer and gave him a
security guard outfit
he would walk around all day patrol
thinking he's the [ __ ] too
he was nuts so he would call my dad at
three in the morning like kevin they
broke in kevin they broke in again i got
them i shot one
he didn't do anything but he would like
so my dad would rush down there and he
would event these big break-ins so like
tell my dad like he was earning his keep
which it was so [ __ ] fun
but yeah man that was great it was it
was a big trash company
and they had brush they brushed up with
the mob a couple times people would
steal dumpsters that was a big thing
they'd steal your dumpsters yeah you'd
find out you'd have to deal with it but
no he
he said he had a couple people i think
the way he uh a couple
i'm trying to phrase it in his language
a couple of goombas try to
shoulder up to him a couple elbow up to
him a couple times he told him to [ __ ]
off
he rollerbladed away
because that's the other thing too it's
like you know with a again you have a
family-owned trash business so you can
get rid of any
so if somebody if you were to try to
kill somebody you easily can
if you wanna you can make that body
disappear real quick yeah if you want an
excavator and a trash company
and the only people that work with you
and your brothers you can totally kill
people and get away with it
so you know and he he was kind of uh
he had one of his friends was kind of
tied in r.i.p
the guy just died recently but he was
his dad had been kind of tied into some
organized crime stuff so like
he they like knew you know it was like
the whole ridley park mob
families thing there's like a whole
bunch of them yeah
so yeah he's like i don't do that [ __ ]
i'm a hard worker but
so it was like you know but that element
was definitely around man yeah i can
imagine he probably had to
you know sidestep a couple of things and
do to deal with some [ __ ] like that
yeah he had to go to court one time when
i was little i remember him mentioning
something about rico charges and there
was someone that he knew
got brought in on rico charges and they
had to ask him some questions or
something
awesome dude the trash business in the
80s and 90s and [ __ ] delco
what the [ __ ] he's leaving your mom's
hanging out the window you don't tell
them nothing
yeah well was it crazy because it back
then too it was like in order to have a
transfer station they only let
back then it was like the wild west was
like anyone could have a trash company
but then the transfer station you needed
to come up with some sort of money so
that's why him and all his brothers
put all of their houses they took
mortgages out in all their houses and
just rolled the dice on the transfer
station and
[ __ ] love that so it didn't work it
was like it would have been a whole
different story for the mccusker family
dude
you'd be doing security at somebody
else's [ __ ] dressed up
that was awesome man i remember being
little like i would when i was like nine
years old i would go to work for i would
sit in a trash truck with him
and i would just listen to cb radio all
day long of different truckers talking
yeah i would hear this is not it was
just slurs constantly so i'm like dad
what does that mean he would be like
that's what that's what they call indian
guys don't tell your mom all right and
then i'm like what's that one he's like
don't tell
anybody that one you can't say that
and then i would get out of the truck
from like learning slurs all day and
then
he would let me shoot rat we would turn
they had a big warehouse where they
would turn the lights on and then rats
would scatter
so you could sit there with a nine
millimeter turn the lights on as soon as
the rats started running it was just
you're blasting rats
what you were doing i think i saw that
game on the boardwalk in wildwood
actually
rats and then you go in the trailer
where like they had the computer when
trucks came in you got to weigh them and
see how much they came in with and how
much they left with that's how you
measure the load
and my uncle would just open a drawer it
was all beef jerky and i was like dude
this [ __ ]
rules yeah i was like heaven i would
kill a rat
learn a slur and then eat
dude nothing's better than that you are
the [ __ ] prince of trash
by the way that's the that's the title
of the episode prince of trash
it's so funny because one of the
questions that i came up with i was
going to ask you has you ever been to a
scrap yard but i didn't know you were
scrapyard royalty so yeah yeah and it
was just you and your brother growing up
no i'm one of six so my dad's tents my
dad's one of ten i'm one of six and then
the funny part is once so once the trash
money started getting nice my dad and
his brother
this is before they sold the company
they bought a bunch of uh land out in
ghana valley before anyone lived out
there
and there was these guys living out
there who they think they were out there
making meth
but they were burying they're burying
trash which is illegal you're not
allowed to do that you get a lot of
trouble
um so my dad not you know not knowing my
dad and his brother all in the trash
company they went out there and they
were like
look man you know we went here with the
property inspector you're burying trash
out here i don't know what else you guys
are up to out here but
like we'll buy it off you but we're
going to buy it off you for super cheap
otherwise we're going to tell people
that you've been burying trash out here
because it's going to cost us a lot of
money to get rid of it because what are
we going to do with all this trash
so they kind of like weaseled these guys
out of being like look you bury trash
out here it's going to cost us a lot and
they just
removed it for free and got all this all
this land out there for
you know your dad sitting there like
what are we gonna do with all this
buried trash
and meanwhile there's like 15 trucks
just waiting at the end of the driveway
how was the meth how was the meth did
anybody get a taste i never tried it man
there was this weird little shack i was
there was like this weird shack up there
it was it was weird man there was a
so then so like my dad and his brother
had this property and then they had this
guy i guess who had already been living
there or i don't know what happened but
this other guy who's a trucker
so it was like my uncle was here with
his family they had 10
kids i was next door on this one piece
of land with six kids and we would all
play but then there was this guy
who lived up the driveway from us who
was a trucker who like had
raccoons as pets it was [ __ ] weird
dude christ dude we were like go we
would feed his raccoons urkel cereal i
remember that
and then like we would walk on his fence
he didn't like us crossing his fans
like [ __ ] you bernie
[Laughter]
dude i would have never guessed this
background for you in a million years
that's wild great i grew up kind of on
like a cousin compound of like 20 people
and with like there was i remember
finally seeing a cop
like when i was like 14 and being like
holy [ __ ] there's a cop out here
it was like completely you know what the
[ __ ] you want it yeah it was awesome
jesus christ that's some [ __ ]
hillbilly new money [ __ ] if i've
ever heard it yeah it's pretty cool man
it's pretty well it's been cool though
because i then i got to like you know i
got to go to college
and i've met people i've worked with
people my whole life who are like in
construction so you can wear
construction you're working mostly a lot
of times with felons
or just like the you know the sons of
the boss who are like a different kind
of class
yeah i've been getting i've got to meet
a lot of people like people who
you know work at a scrap yard versus
like people of generational wealth at a
college so it's definitely been weird
mm-hmm
so yeah that's some trippy [ __ ] what a
six too
doing a little [ __ ] i like yeah my
dad's one of ten
and everyone every one of his sisters
yeah every one of his brothers or
sisters have typically
at least five kids is it all you guys
all irish catholic yeah
there you go my mom's one of nine we're
like [ __ ] ticks
yeah dude that's insane
yeah man that was that was the that was
a genesis so that's kind of that's how i
grew
up that's that's the origin story right
yeah yeah
and it was really kind of like my mom
would wake me up you know she would wake
us up at like 8 a.m like get out so then
i would go outside into like a lord of
the fly set up with all my older cousins
and like dude that was like
it was insane man we used to play a game
where me and my cousin would just run
through a field and my older cousins
would just throw like various balls at
us
that's awesome though man i used to i
look at that now and i'm like [ __ ] that
was it was great but yeah
we'd wake up in the morning in the
summer and it'd be like yo
beat it take a [ __ ] hike and you're
gone you're gone until [ __ ] sundown
yeah man it was awesome it was awesome
we go in the woods i remember we had a
uh
it was basically just like we would go
out and my i would just like go outside
and then like my parents would like tell
me what to do all day and then i'd get
out of that to my older cousins be like
you have to fight pat and i'm like [ __ ]
oh dude i have to like fight the
organized fights in a big family
are [ __ ] the best we would be at like
thanksgiving or something i'd go up into
like one of the rooms where all the kids
were and they'd be like hey you got to
fight dan i'm like what
she's just sitting there like cracking
his neck i'm like [ __ ] dude
like this [ __ ] sucks man tummy full
of stuffing in you
yeah oh yeah i got chicken chicken
nuggies in me
i gotta start [ __ ] fighting for my
life yeah my brothers one time put me in
a truck tire and rolled me down a hill
when i was little that's hillbilly they
sent another truck tire up for me to
ramp over
so i hit the other truck tire ramped and
landed on my head upside down and just
crunched in was the first time i got the
air knocked out of me
crunched inwards and then this was like
in a truck tire rolling unable to
breathe until it wobbled over it was
like
and then i could get six people like
don't be a [ __ ] [ __ ] and i'm like
i'm good i'm good i thought i was
everyone's gonna crack sternum stop
being a [ __ ]
you're a mccusker god damn it we're
trash people i'll [ __ ] get up and
let's go
all right let's give him some questions
here play a little are you garbage with
mr matt mccusker
um man that's a [ __ ] wild pale
that is [ __ ] lord of the [ __ ]
swiss family garbanzo
over there
would you guys all take uh vacations
together
uh we no we would like usually when we
would go to the beach that would be my
mom's side of the family which is like a
whole that's like a whole other setup
what's your point where would you what
what bc oh that's that's
that's in the middle of the road that's
on the upper that's on the that's in the
upper 50 percent
yes yeah wow a little bit of that trash
money down there
do they have a short house no they had
one
and then they it was funny they sold it
for like nothing before seattle blew up
and yeah a lot of poorly timed real
estate transactions
a couple of good ones too though yeah
yeah but yeah so they you know they sold
that and then uh like
it was like a little house back before
like it blew up into a big thing but no
they
they had my dad has a house in florida
now that's that's his like
spot he goes down to cape coral just him
or your mom
too my mom yeah they're together okay
you can't that's what he always says you
can't get divorced when you have six
kids
yeah that's highly unmarketable
[Laughter]
from a dating perspective that's always
looking might ruin a bunch it might ruin
30 people's lives
listen trying to get tail when you got
six kids
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] all right um
what do you got kip all right let's go
here um
have you ever went fishing strictly for
catfish
yes oh that's [ __ ] trash have you
ever gone
uh what's it called canoodling no now we
put your toes we used to fish for
catfish and uh
put m80s in their gills and blow them up
go ahead
yeah that's lunatic [ __ ] you were
burning frogs when you were a kid you
[ __ ] yeah
wow did you guys all have guns um well
no we used to do like the uh no there's
like like my dad has yeah they all grew
up like i grew up shooting guns and
stuff but i didn't like get to own one
when i was a kid
you guys didn't get like bb gun
slingshot all that [ __ ]
wrist rockets were [ __ ] cleveland as
a kid yeah weapons survived i had
everyone had to have a survival knife
oh yeah there's some batches inside of
it
yeah we go unscrew them yeah that
unscrew the bottom oh yeah with the
compass on the end this is
pretty sweet once rambo came out it was
a wrap on those things
[ __ ] gimme you thought you were so
cool walking around the house with that
thing on your hip or something
[ __ ] so cool butterfly knife yeah we
had some weapons dude
um yeah all right what do you got foley
uh
growing up as a kid um would you have
creamy peanut butter or chunky peanut
butter
chunky that's garbage
and i love it it's new that's new money
stuff
that's new money right there the chunky
that's what your dad said to you when he
pulled up in an
alligator now on maddie you're getting
extra chunky kid
things have changed tell your mom to go
in there and throw that skippy creamy
out the window
because daddy sold the company
anyone in your family own a pontoon boat
yes my dad
man he is ricky bobby that's [ __ ]
awesome we got to get this guy on
dude pontoon boats are the trashiest of
the
of the boats dude that's just for people
who want to get
[ __ ] up and are tired of drinking on
land that's all that is
let's do the follow-up did your family
own any all-terrain vehicles
four-wheelers three-wheelers oh we had
to get rid of them all because two of my
cousins went to the hospital on the same
day
one time so we had to get rid of all the
atvs and dirt bikes well they i think
they
no i think they got yeah they got rid of
them we had atvs and dirt bikes and go
cars
did you ever have a strike no never had
uh
no no i don't think we did i've rode one
but my dad said they're too dangerous
they flip it over
yeah this thing that was a big myth in
the 90s those things would just [ __ ]
turn over what happened to your cousins
uh
well so my it was we had one we had one
one of the dirt bikes we had
my cousin tried to he tried to ramp uh
like
not a sand mound but like there was a
thing in the front yard you could
definitely get air off of it
so he ramped that and then the like the
break caught his lip
and ripped his lip open
yeah so he got fish hooked and ripped
his lip and then on the same day my
cousin had this you know he went to the
hospital and then my other cousin hopped
on the derp like
it was riding it and fell over and got a
30 degree burn on his life
jesus right so after that there was a
discussion he was like alright we gotta
like you know they were my cousins all
got hurt and we were like what the [ __ ]
we didn't get hurt why do we have to get
rid of the dirt bikes my [ __ ] yes
my cousins are [ __ ] blah blah so you
know
so this is just the whole brew just
running around in this [ __ ]
compound it'd be like a go-kart going
with two people in it we need a two-man
go-kart
multiple times two-man go-kart a
four-wheeler and like a moped and a dirt
bike we're buzzing around at all times
man that is garbage
new money [ __ ] right there i [ __ ]
love it
holy [ __ ] did you guys have like a robot
that just served drinks or something
like that
you seem like the kind of people who
would like train your dog to get you a
beer too
like they can open up the fridge with
yeah bring your bud heavy no matter how
much money you guys have you still use
the white foam coolers
[Laughter]
so one of the basics is so obviously i'm
assuming you had a garage
on your house yeah yeah we had a garage
attached to the house turn that into a
living room
and then build an exterior garage wow
that's three different that's three
different bad answers right there that
you just gave me in that one sentence
any time you turn an existing garage
into a living room
it's [ __ ] trash dude you gotta take
that little step down into it it's
always
colder no matter how much padding you
put on that floor you can tell you're
walking on a concrete slab
[Laughter]
i forgot about that yeah i'm like yeah i
do step down out of the kitchen into the
living room then up back into the mud
room
yeah it's too funny it's like a split
level
um and then i so in the proper garage
the new one you built which is a class
move
that's a new money move but class move
yeah um did you have a refrigerator in
there
oh no i i think we have a
no we didn't actually we had a
refrigerator in our basement and
we have a second floor my dad used to
have another hobby used to make bullets
on the second floor of the new garage
what make bullets you can make bullets
yeah if you buy one
or something you can buy bullet parts
and make bullets so i used to make
bullets up on the second part of the
garage
this guy's a [ __ ] loose cannon this
guy's gonna end up on a list or
something
pontoon boats making
[Laughter]
i love how he's got an armory on the
second floor of the garage but no one's
allowed to ride a dirt bike
yeah like it could explode he had
gunpowder up there yeah exactly
um so you did have a second there were
you were you had a second fridge in the
house
yeah yeah what was in there beer beer
yeah
just beer left over from family parties
yeah clean living
that's the garage the garage fridge is
real big with us yeah
so yeah i've seen a lot of garage it was
usually like it was like a
fridge full of beers that have allegedly
been counted but you could take six and
nobody would notice that
yeah just kind of spread them out a
little bit so it still looks full
yeah when you guys are all coming of age
you guys must have been [ __ ]
out there boozing your heads off yeah i
i started drinking beer like i remember
i would like a summer day of mine this
is i sort of got it like
10 years 11 years old was i would pocket
a silver bullet
meet my cousins in the woods and we
would all like six of us would share a
silver boy
yeah and then we would fight me my
cousin would for just like roll up
leaves and smoke them like random leaves
on the ground we were just dude we did
that too
yeah yeah yeah sugar packets we'd roll
up sugar packets and smoke them
i picture you guys the kind of people
who would like shoot the top off your
beer can
and then drink it
yeah before we before we discovered you
remember when wawa used to leave
the black milds down like it wasn't like
up behind the register they were down to
the right or left
yeah they were just sitting down on a
ground level stand so before we would
then before after the twigs smoking
enough twigs were like oh we're gonna
steal black and mild then we would steal
black and wilds and smoke black miles
jesus yeah black and mild is a 14 year
old that was [ __ ] you were you were
the [ __ ] boss of the neighborhood
because
we found this lady at like the quick
mart or whatever it was called crousers
she would she was like she would sell us
cigars because we were 14. she thought
that was the law she's like i can't sell
you cigarettes
i can sell you cigars we were just
smoking [ __ ] smoking philly blunts
and black and milds like you know
we were like an old mob boss yeah we had
a store
at the so i grew up near boost corners
it's a farmer's market
and there was a it's so finale thing
about it so illegal there was a guy in
there it was called the whatnot shop
and he would sell 70s playboys and
butterfly knives to kids
so you'd go in there this guy would sell
kids porn and weapons
that's great is that guy still around i
don't i don't know if the shop's still
in there anymore he must have made it
must have a million dollars cash
[Laughter]
it's all in ones and [ __ ]
60 ones yeah he's waiting there with a
hammer to crack open your piggy bank
it was like [ __ ] we had a fort set up
and like you could go there and just
like buy 70s playboys and like buy all
the [ __ ] you needed for
for like matches knives playboys this
guy was
he had like the direct pipeline to like
11 year olds those old playboys man they
were they were something else
all bush yeah it was all they were
something else
girls with girls
what was the name of the grocery store
your mom went to when you were growing
up janardi's
oh nice
i went to high school with the
generality you did you yeah they got a
little bit of
gish i don't know who they sold it to
but they sold it to somebody
for a couple of fazoles a few years ago
i bet man my mom
they bought so her grocery bill was so
high that like canard
ginartis did some sort of reward program
where they gave us a double
tape set of titanic for free you're like
yeah they're like just want a little
token of appreciation so you guys still
got it
no i don't know i think my mom took it
because you saw there's tits in it and
we were how about a couple of [ __ ]
steaks over here i got six growing kids
[ __ ] titanic i think i want kate
winslet let's do it here
and i was like sweet that's poor person
mentality of like hey
i just spent you know over the past
month i spent 15 grand here
and they gave me a promotional copy of
the titanic on vhs
we are living over here it's poor people
[ __ ] my mom does the same thing
they have gennard's plug sliced into it
[Laughter]
jack where are you going to janardis
i love the way they slice their meat uh
okay anyone in your family please
scratch off lottery tickets
nah i think my brother messes with them
secretly
but i don't know yeah i think my brother
might but not not like
not in heaven it was never something
that was uh like
it was never something big i feel like
especially my in my immediate family
definitely not
but have you or any member of your
family ever called a sports radio show
yeah yeah for sure yeah again not my
immediate fan
my uncle used to call them all the time
uh he was driving a trash truck yeah he
would [ __ ] with him and mess with him
all the time
wow that's pretty funny then if you're
doing it you know if you're doing it as
a bit
yeah i mean my uncles would for sure but
my my dad my family
my immediate family nobody my dad never
watched sports so like none of us ever
watched sports or i still to this day
could give a [ __ ] yeah
um growing up did you have uh the
three-in-one fisher price table the
basketball the ping-pong and the air
hockey table
oh no we had we had an air hockey table
but not the three in one
oh we had a proper air hockey table yeah
we had a real deal here that's real
really
in the basement what about a pool table
no we never had a pool table no bumper
pool no bumper pool no
the ultimate trash purchase of like you
know somebody who gets a little bit of
scratch and as an alcoholic is the
shuffleboard table in the basement
my uncle jim has a shuffleboard table
here uncle jimmy
i'm coming over i'm coming home for
christmas jimmy dude it's awesome i love
going to their house yeah
it's crazy it's awesome full
shuffleboard table and a pool table in
his basement
it's also trash to have the basketball
game
like the set up one with that dude my
one cousin has
that it's [ __ ] dude
hours just down there [ __ ] drinking
beers and [ __ ] draining threes
um dart boards are typically trashy but
if you get the wooden thing like the
wooden door with like the chalk on the
inside
that's real nice yeah that is true matt
you ever played a game of horseshoes
yes we support horseshoes and family
parties yeah we had it set up
you had the pit back there dude i
remember my dad built a pit for like a
july 4th barbecue or something i thought
we were the [ __ ] richest kids on the
block i was like wait till these [ __ ]
come over here
and see this [ __ ] horseshoe pit
what about what's the grilling situation
over at uh mom and dad's you have a
you have a grill yeah i got a grill is
it is it like a one with like a propane
tank propane
because i pegged you for a [ __ ]
charcoal forget kind of family uh
dissolved all propane all propane all
right
um growing up did you ever have a good
fellows poster in your room
or sopranos no i had wu-tang at the
wu-tang clan poster in my room
all right respectable respectable
i want to talk about christmas yeah uh
would your mom decorate the lawn
no it's funny actually i would complain
that we didn't do decorations and she
handed me a bow and a hammer a bunch of
bows and hammers like nellie's to the
fence and
[Laughter]
not even inside there was no clothes you
would put the candles in the window she
put the camp plug-in candles in the
window so we were
plugging candles yeah per window and
then
i think we did lights once or twice and
then they just stopped they're like
we're not doing this so it would be like
we had a couple elves on the stairs and
then
put a candle in every window that's
pretty classy that's right you do a real
tree or a fake tree
real tree yeah colored lights or white
lights
uh colored and white actually like the
traditional
like red green those kind of colors like
the roygee biff full set up here
yeah yikes damn okay would you do a
tinsel on the tree
no no tinsel just lights lights and
balls
okay does your family drink eggnog no
would you open christmas presents on
christmas eve for christmas day
one on christmas eve after we went to
midnight mass oh
midnight mass wrong with it
here we go that's a classy answer right
there sometime that midnight
that midnight may have sucked because it
would be like the vigil and you'd be
sitting there with like
if you go on for like three hours it
[ __ ] sucked you're hot smells like
[ __ ] old spice in there
like once you get to that certain point
you you can't help but think about
what am i getting tomorrow oh for sure
it's just like time is just like
dragging so slow i used to [ __ ] hate
that yeah i used to be
i used to be scared going to bed another
christmas eve i don't want some [ __ ]
fat guy rooting through my [ __ ] house
want another fat guy roding through your
house
what if he eats all the cookies
he's not gonna drink all the milk is he
oh there you go
uh growing up milk with dinner oh yeah
for sure
yeah spaghetti spaghetti and meatballs
and milk
oh yes so good crazy
cheeseburgers and milk oh dude that's
[ __ ]
trash you know my favorite is my
favorite it's pizza and milk
yeah right do you still do it mccusker
if i have
uh if i have like spaghetti any kind of
red sauce it's like a cup of milk is the
accompanied
house in a wine glass what does your
wife say
jesus like whatever she don't care oh
wow
that's crazy um all right on that same
note growing up uh
in the house would your mom buy brisk
iced tea
was like the juice boxes or like the
pre-made mix no it'd be like the can of
brisk
you remember no it wasn't a state my mom
was a health nut so she didn't really
let us have i wasn't allowed to have
soda before noon growing up
but admirable rule the bread's pretty
classy it was kind of nice the brisk was
uh
no that was like a family party treat we
didn't have soda stocked in the house
only for pizza night we would get soda
pizza night was clean friday pizza night
was
all right did you guys would you do like
dominoes
or pizza hut or would you what where
were you a pizza at family or dogs
bounced around we were
whatever corporation was giving us free
vhs's that's where our loyalties lied
yeah we were dominoes we were big cheese
for a while we bounced you know
yeah all right pretty good let's talk
about your house now
yeah uh let's go into the
the bathroom your house now not growing
up
what are you rocking in there you got
some body wash are you using a bar
got a bar bar wow
i tried to do the bar but i i just like
i don't know i just always for you know
the loof then you got to buy a new
loofah the luffa
explodes and it's like i just do the bar
bar directly to body
yeah really bar directly in the body
what are you rocking uh
i don't know i just i got some
what is it i bought like soap right now
now i'm boujee i bought soap from whole
foods so i got 10 for 10.
little goats milk soap something like
that so for 10 bucks yeah
god damn is that where you guys shop is
whole foods yeah
sometimes we'll do whole foods or
sprouts depending but sprouts
sprouts is just another grocery store
near us
is it organic or is it nah it's not as
like crazy as whole foods but it's it's
definitely not it's like a step up from
acme it's better than acme and then in
terms of
organicness less than whole foods but
still good comparison sounds fancy as
[ __ ]
living the life down there i like this
sound bad and bougie
what's your snack situation my snack
uh what do i i don't i don't really
i have like a weird i have a bunch of
weird dietary so from my mom was a
health nut because she my mom had a
gluten allergy in the 70s when people
were just like that's not even a real
thing nobody even bothered that's like
nobody believes a witch they'd make fun
of her all the time for it and then so i
have my mom's
system with food i have like a bunch of
weird food allergies that's why i have
to i shop at like uh
like fancier grocery stores but yeah i
ate pretty clean man i eat like
you know like i made i'll be like
brisket and i'm a beat potatoes kind of
dude and then i force myself to eat
vegetables
okay i don't really eat snacks i'll eat
like tortilla chips and hummus that's it
did you get snacks growing up did your
mom hook it up little dunkaroos little
shark bites so she was yeah fruit snacks
were a battle she
my mom had like a weird thing and then
it was like
so it was weird in terms of like salt
levels like i would eat
i would when i snack wise growing up i
would take
uh like you know the 24 pack of bagel
bites
i think i could fit like nine bagel
bites or i think it was actually like 12
on a plate and i would microwave 12
bagel bites
while that was going i would i would put
spaghettios and i would dip bagel bites
and spaghettios and eat them and my mom
wouldn't blink an eye but if i ate like
that's bad for you that might be the
trashiest meal we've heard and we had
somebody who said they microwaved
[ __ ] burgers last week
yeah i said microwave bagel bites you
got to eat them real quick because like
that by the end of it they would turn to
cement
yeah you could eat the last one chilling
on it'd be tough dude it'd be like yeah
yeah meatballs dude growing up my snacks
was [ __ ] up dude i was eating real bad
dude i forgot about spaghettios man we
used to [ __ ] have them all the time
so [ __ ] good they were so good yeah
the meatballs are good
how bad must that have been for us like
was that even meat
yeah i mean also too the sodium in those
are like
unbelievably through the roof i would
eat one of those every single day can of
spaghettios
as many bagels the bagel bites would
eventually run out there was like
toaster
toaster strudel situation was like by
the end of the week
you know they had like the icing packets
and the strudel yeah at the end of the
week you'd have to eat like a naked
strudel that would be like yeah
but dude you had [ __ ] toaster shroom
man that's fancy
yeah yeah we stepped out from pop tarts
and toasted strudels and then we got the
toaster strudels taken away because
we were fighting over icing packets
because people were doubling up sure
yeah strudels were definitely a conflict
heavy
snack but for sure alliances are drawn
yeah
yeah so that was it my snacks were like
my dad was like a total
food monster my mom's like a health nut
so we were always like somewhere between
damn very interesting do you change your
own oil
no did your dad
uh i don't think so man i mean i know he
knows how to do all that stuff but it's
like i don't i doubt it honestly
interesting quite the conundrum here
yeah all right i think i only got one
more here um
[Music]
let's see that one's for sure i mean i
was going to ask you if you've ever been
in the back of a pickup truck but
you know first four years of your life
there um
have you ever worn a wife beater in
public yeah for sure
tough luck for sure so like a store or
something
yeah i mean i've worn them especially
when i was younger like to the boardwalk
obviously you're in a white theater no
doubt oh yeah of course
that was like all day long well yeah
i've definitely worn white feeders in
public
if the board's in a beater pair of board
shorts
yeah dude grab it arizona tall boy and
just post up
trying to get numbers dude try to get
maybe a necklace with a shark tooth on
it have you got a couple of bucks on you
it's like a bright red sunburned face
plus you tonight
yeah i have like nine bucks on my in my
pocket
it's all you needed down there baby get
an ice cream and an auntie anne's
pretzel or something
oh yeah it was awesome all right i just
got one last question for you and i
think
i think you're gonna pass the test on
this one um growing up
your ketchup was kept in the fridge or
in the cabinet
dude i don't know because i never used
ketchup i'm all barbecue sauce for any
anything on ketchup i just use barbecue
sauce but my wife keeps it
in the cabinet and i think it we kept it
in the fridge
i don't know honestly i have no idea
your wife keeps the ketchup in the
cabin yeah you got to rethink this
marriage i don't know
is it serious how it's going on here
yeah she keeps it in the cab
all right here's the final question wait
hold on put a pin in that what do you
where do you keep the barbecue sauce
fridge okay yeah barbecue sauce making
sure i'm not dealing with an animal over
here
i think you [ __ ] know a guy over here
he's not surprised i know this guy 10
[ __ ] years he's keeping his ketchup
in a cabinet
and my last question is the syrup where
would you keep the syrup in the cabinet
or in the fridge
but my mom would eat the my mom gets
like the maple she will get pure maple
syrup
keep it in the chest all class that's
the final verdict right there
what are you talking about he just
answered [ __ ] every question as
trash as possible for the last 55
minutes he keeps his
his sarah in the right place also he's
classy but this is
new money it's this to me he's like a
kennedy you know what i mean
that's what everybody in my neighborhood
strives to be did you hear them
sold the trash business they're doing
very well
they scammed some land off a couple guys
out in garnet valley that will cook and
met
they're going to build a compound out
there the kids are going out there too
well once i open syrup i'll put it in
the fridge just for a good measure
yeah you gotta play it safe a little bit
but i don't mind if the syrup is out of
the fridge
it's to me it doesn't matter i gotta all
right one more while we're on this
these are all very recurring uh butter
did you keep it in the fridge or like on
the counter growing up it was out all
day but it was not out as long as my
aunt marsha's butter and milk would sit
out all
like my cousins next door their milk
would get a sip of milk over there and
it was always like
hang on a second there's something wrong
with my earphones
what'd you say warm milk water they
would set out what
because they had 10 kids so like they
were the cereal set up was like you
would use it the milk would be in and
out of the fridge like someone would
pour themselves in a bowl of cereal and
leave that milk out the butter
our butter sat out all day long it was
by dinner time you could just you know
pop that yeah that's great that's
awesome kevin thinks that's trash i
think that's fantastic that's how you do
it yeah but
their milk sat out pretty much all day
long it was weird because it went it
went so quick it was probably a gal a
day
so but if you got milk in the afternoon
it was ready to go
damn room another level of garbage oh
dude it was wicked i would pour myself
like a glass of milk over there
like choking it like what the [ __ ] is
this
i'm like i think i hear my mom and just
like [ __ ] mosey out of there fire the
glass right in the sink yo ain't get
your [ __ ] together it was like cat milk
it's like a warm bowl of milk dude i
can't do that man
my milk's got to be ice cold and whole
that's the way
uncle gotta be screaming cold wow
man your cousins definitely garbage yeah
he's definitely garbage what are you
talking about this kid's [ __ ]
treasure
he's got a globe behind him what are you
talking about
he's got a master's degree come on do
you have a master's degree yeah i got a
master's degree in social work and i
almost killed damn almost got kicked out
because of all the
nonsense with the podcast but i stayed
in really
yeah they tried the students try to
assemble and kick me out but
some of them [ __ ] last year you were you
were going for your masters
social work doesn't really count but
when everything went down
they tried to kick you out of school
yeah well it's just the students this is
how they are man they try to like rally
together and be like we need him out
here
i also would argue with everybody the
whole time during class because they
would
it was just [ __ ] so i'd be like nah
[ __ ] that and then they didn't like me
anyway and then once they found that
once they they found some dirt on me
they're like
he's out but i was just like all right
kick me i was like hoping they would
kick me out i'm like i'm gonna
[ __ ] turn this in i'll just you know
this will be a good thing for my podcast
yeah it's right content yeah you also
can't kick me out so i sat there with
the president and was like
you know nice lady too but i was like
yeah yeah you guys really can't kick me
out it'll be a bad
bad look do you mind saying what school
or no bryn mawr yeah that's fine
oh wow oh yeah that was gonna say it had
to be a small it had to be a tight
tight crew yeah did you say it to the to
the lady that scary is that like
kick me out but it's gonna be a bad look
for you no i i kind of said i was like
you know and
she she's very very sweet i i really
liked the lady but i i was i was being
honest because she was being nice to me
and i was like look man i'll be honest i
you know
i can stay here i don't mind staying but
there's a part of my brain that knows
how to take advantage of situations and
that part's thinking like if you guys
kick me out
i would definitely you know i would i
would work with that as much as i could
sure yeah yeah i like how he's tiptoeing
around the words then
that's very old trash money
matt mccusker i say all class kippy says
garbage
uh either way you're absolutely
fantastic in our books buddy
thank you so much for coming on the show
it's great to see you great to catch up
with you
thank you um other than matt and shane's
secret podcast
that everybody loves is there anything
you want the uh the folks out there to
know
yeah i'm doing it so after i got my
master's degree i started i launched i'm
launching a project it's a it's a
auxiliary podcast but it's
psycho-educational called psycnol
okay i'm trying to build peer-to-peer
networks for people who can't afford
therapy or just
obviously don't want to pay a [ __ ]
hundred dollars an hour i'm gonna try to
guide the content through a podcast and
set up four-man groups where people can
take like you can go on the website's
being built but it's like anxiety
depression whatever you can click
whatever one you want and then you'll be
launched into a four-man group
where you can have like four people to
check in and have something to say you
know it's not as good i guess it's
traditional therapy but it's better and
it's free
something that's [ __ ] awesome man
congratulations holy [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
great
yep that's what i'm using my degree for
i love it kippy what do you got
just uh you know thanks again matt you
were after [ __ ] shane's episode
everybody flooded in and was like you
got to get [ __ ] mccusker
so we appreciate you doing it yeah just
uh make sure if you haven't already
please rate review subscribe on itunes
and also full video available on youtube
you can subscribe there and the [ __ ]
patreon
just started cooking let's go [ __ ]
yes sir guys thank you so much for
uh for everything uh h foley on ice on
twitter
uh foleygrams on instagram uh thank you
so much for supporting the podcast we
appreciate you
matt mccuster matt mccusker love you
buddy love you guys man appreciate it
buddy we'll see you guys
later